- Ça, c'est une AR de Armalite,
- Ce copropriétaire d'un centre
de tir dde tir de l'Outaouais ns
présente les armes qui sont dans
- C'est une carabine,maximum 10.
- Ottawa dévoile les montants
aux propriétaires d'armes
dites d'assaut de type militaire
interdites, allant, par exemple,
jusqu'à 6209 $ pour un SSG-550
plus sophistiqué.
Dans certains cas,
de tous les coûts encourus
par les propriétaires, qui sont
nombreux à modifier leur armes,
déplore Pierre Pharand.
HARAND, copropriétaire,
Club de tir de l'Outaouais
que quand on l'a achetée.
Il y a des gens qui vont
être extrêmement déçus.
- Combien ce programme
coûtera-t-il au trésor public?
Difficile d'évaluee d'évaluee dc
certitude, puisqu'on ne sait pas
combien de ces armes
Le directeur parlementaire
t estimait, en 2021,
que la mesure pourrait
coûter jusqu'à 756 millions
Cher, mais nécessaire,
selon les militants militants ms
pour le contrôle des armes.
NATHALIE PROVOST,nt
- C'est une très grosse dépense,
mais je pense que la sécurité
de mes enfants, des enfants
et notre sécurité en dépend.e rt
obligatoire ont fait
leurs preuves dans d'autres
pays, selon cet expert.ocié
Observatoire sur les États-Uniss
bien fonctionné, ça a ramené
au-dessus de 600 000 armes gouv.
- Les opposants au programme
jugent que l'interdiction cible
injustement les propriétaires
légitimes et non le
des propriétaires prendront
l'argent du rachat pour
se procurer d'autres modèles
de fusils qui ne fiste d'interd.
MARTIN BOURGET, Association
canadienne des armes à feu
- Effectivement, il y a
d'autressortir, il y a d'autress
existants présente
lesquels les utilisateurs vont
se virer, donc vouque le problèt
juste le reporter.
- Une faille qu'il faut
corriger
PolySeSouvient. Il réclame
une inteasée sur
les caractéristiques d'une arme,
plutôt
jugée facile à contourner.
- Seul le rachat ne rachat ne rs
être complet. Il faut absolument
comment les armes sont
caractérisées.
- En attendant,
les propriétaires visés doivente
en échange d'une compensation
ou la rendre inutilisable
aux frais du gouvernement.urs qt
dit qu'ils ne retourneront pas
leur arme. Maintenant, entre ce
qu'ils disent et ce qu'ils vont.
- Le prorachat
devrait être mis en oeuvre
d'ici la fin de l'année.
jusqu'au 30 octobre 2023 pour
rmer à l'interdiction.
Ici Louis Blouin,
Radio-C